Charlene see last question what was it
like filming North and South with
Patrick Swayze he was filming a few
hours from me in Charleston what do you
remember about him well that's when I
fell in love with my wife Jeannie
Francis who played Patrick Swayze's
sister
Swayze was
he was the mayor of Charleston by the
way when we were down there it was a it
was the 80s need I say anymore
he was Patrick Swayze
and
I loved him he had a huge heart
very talented great Horseman
great man
um
and he carried that I mean he was he was
a good movie star yeah you know what
happened to him
he died from pancreatic cancer
pancreatic cancer where can people go if
they want a pancan.org pancan.org
there's support there there's a it's a
it's one of the biggest Killers well
it's not like that it's the survival
rate is so shitty when my brother died
it was a three percent survival rate now
it's up to 12 which is a big deal so
Swayze was awesome Charleston was
awesome I remember taking my wife on my
wife Jeannie asking Genie out on a date
and we went to 82 Queen Street and with
the in the in the cast where uh Kirsty
alley was in the cast and she was like
the the uh
the gang leader right you know and we'd
all hang out together and go out dancing
and all that stuff and I said to
Christian I really think I like chibi
and she'd say it's okay freaks I think
Genie likes you I think you should ask
her out she was like we go to the
counselor for for advice
he was a riot you remember that like
it's yesterday oh I also remember David
Carradine was also in the show David
Carradine and Patrick Swayze were in the
23rd floor of the hotel we were staying
in and that was where the bar was and I
don't know what they were what they had
had but
there were big shutters it was South
there were big Shutters on the Windows
of this of this uh lounge or whatever it
was in the hotel
and Swayze said
I Can Fly
and decarity and said you I could
fly so they both ran towards the windows
and we had to tackle them both
oh my God you know what a true story I
have an animator sometimes that will
animate clips of this podcast and I
think that right that's the one I might
have Swayze crazy
you I could fly